good morning nurses at 117 NHS trusts in
England along with others in Scotland
Wales and Northern Ireland could be out
on strike Before Christmas a and Ian
ambulance care will remain as normal but
non-urgent clinics will be forced to
slow down which will mean patients
facing cancellations and delays and it's
not just nurses do you need doctors
midwives ambulance drivers
physiotherapists Hospital Porters and
cleaners are all balloting for
industrial action they're demanding a
pay increase that keeps up with
inflation but a joint report out this
morning from the new economic foundation
and Trade union Congress says the NHS
needs an extra 15 billion pounds a year
just to maintain current services
this action is about speaking up for
patients it's about ensuring that those
patients don't languish on waiting lists
any longer and they won't if we are able
to fill the vacant posts if we're able
to hold on to the nurses by giving them
a decent wage and ensuring that this
Health Service is fit for purpose
well Johnny is now is Northern Ireland
secretary Chris Heaton Harris
representing the government this morning
hello thanks for joining us on the
program lots to talk about with Northern
Ireland I know you made a statement
yesterday lunchtime after pmqs but first
let's talk about nurses should we I'm
going to give them any more money
um
well they are getting some more money I
mean that nurses pay has been set set by
independent bodies for quite some time
and uh and that award has been made and
will be and will be paid and
um but you know it I want to say like
everybody would like to that you know
nurses doctors everybody in the NHS went
that extra mile during the time of the
pandemic actually they were the only
group of people who got a pay Rise
um in the public sector in the pandemic
three percent pay Rise
um and um
but the ask of the RCN the Royal College
of Nursing at 17
um is is a high ask and I believe even
even labor say they can't afford that
nurses get paid enough as it is
um that's very difficult to judge I mean
I I was looking at the pay bands it's
not my area of expertise as you'd
understand I know but yeah no no exactly
right uh and um you know I know it's a
vocation
um I suppose you could say Politics as a
vocation in many ways
um and a a nurse will start on 27 000
pounds rising to I think it's bad Five
band Six in the in the kind of low to
mid 30 000 pounds is that enough
I mean who put a value on something on
care like that
mention
um uh politicians do nurses deserve as
much pay as politicians
um
well some people wouldn't want to pay
politicians anything so I think nurses
not my question I know but I'm a
politician uh I think that's an unfair
question because we're in completely
different places but nurses are using
food banks they're saying and having to
eat leftover food that patients have not
eaten yeah I've heard those stories too
and and they're troubling and actually
very very sad but everything the
government is doing across the whole of
of public sector pay which is the only
pay sector that we can influence is is
aiming at the the lower paid and the
more more vulnerable in society as well
when we offer more packages of support
um so we understand that we need to help
people a bit more
um Minister the education secretary was
on yesterday said there's no point in
nurses going on strike because there's
no more money
um do you agree with that
I think well I used to be brown Minister
I used to engage with the Royal unions a
a huge amount and actually I do think
there's uh those discussions are
actually generally valuable because
politicians will
unless we come from the background that
we of the department that in rail I
wasn't a real women so I needed to
understand better the asks of conditions
the industry itself
um so the engagement is definitely worth
a thing but yeah Public public sector
finances are uh not in the best of
shapes and we're trying to stabilize our
economy make sure we drive it forward so
uh you know there are better times ahead
um but 17 ask is a very big ask in
public safety terms so just to clarify
is it a pointless strike because there's
no more money for nurses um
I'd never say strike is pointless but
this completely disrupts a huge host of
Public Services
that are very very important to the
whole nation and dialogue is always the
best way
um
what about nurses in Northern Ireland
who do they negotiate with yeah that's a
really good question because up until
the 28th of October
um that had been a negotiation with the
minister for health uh there currently
there is no Minister and so
um I'm afraid some of those
responsibilities now fall to me you keep
kicking in the can down the road what's
the latest situation um
it's a can that everybody else wants to
kick down the road everybody says to me
that elections in Northern Ireland at
this point in time will just polarize
Society a great deal more and actually
come up with no no different results and
so the latest situation is yesterday in
the House of Commons
I was going to
try and get some primary legislation
through the house to delay the elections
to the new year to give time and space
to two very important things for the
North Nine parties to come together for
more discussions about going back into
the assembly so local people can make
local choices
um on their constituents behalf but also
so the UK government and the European
commission can have some time and space
to talk and negotiate about the Northern
Ireland protocol which is one of the key
reasons why the unionist community in
Northern Ireland
um and their representatives won't go
into the executive
um usefully on Ireland correspondent
David Blevins I was chatting to him last
night and he pointed out that on the 3rd
of October you said you would push the
button and call a stormbound election if
Devolution had not been restored by the
28th of October then on the 18th of
October you told the Northern Ireland
Affairs committee you would call an
election a Devolution had not been
restored by the 28th of October then on
the 28th of October you said you were
disappointed that the evolution had not
been restored and would be calling an
election yesterday you said you wouldn't
be calling an election forgive me for
being a politician that listens to
people but I did when when so on the one
minute past midnight on the 28th of
October the responsibility of all
ministers disappeared in Northern
Ireland so and there's a very very big
budget black hole in Northern in
Northern Ireland's finances and all
those responsibilities fell to me I've
been talking to all the political
parties I've been talking to businesses
to community groups to uh ordinary folk
on the streets and no one wanted an
election
um and uh and I've now done something
that creates the time and space for
conversations to take place so the
executive hopefully can reform and for
conversations to take place between as I
say the UK government and the European
commission
um to try and solve one of the biggest
obstacles to that what's the big problem
uh in which way there's always problems
um the big problem is the protocol
and for the unionist community because
it means a whole host of goods are not
available in Northern Ireland that
should be and are available in the rest
of of Great Britain and that needs to be
solved
how do you do that by negotiations with
showing trust and respect with the
European commission as far as the
European commission is concerned and
indeed the European courts EU law your
boss Rishi sunak has said that oh he's
certainly talking tough when he was
chatting to me in the summer as saying
that EU law most of it would be scrap it
would have nothing to do with us by the
end of his tenure by the next election
is that something that you agree with
yeah I mean so it's it's for all you
laws already been transposed onto our
statute books and the bits that are
remaining the references to European law
uh there's a bill going through the
House of Commons at this very point in
time to remove those so how do you see
the 2023 how do you see this being fixed
you talk about the Northern Ireland
protocol we know that the Northern
Ireland protocol is an incredibly
vexatious subject that no one seems to
be able to fix yeah I mean it has been
like that
um and firstly can I I should say that
when it was written I honestly don't
think the people mind writing it thought
it would have the ramifications in it I
thought it was oven ready this time no
no the the the protocol so politicians
are legislators legislators are are very
good at creating law but when the rubber
hits the road sometimes you get
unforeseen consequences so uh Paris
Johnson was wrong to say that it was an
oven ready deal
um no it was an oven ready to do and the
European commission who also who
co-authored the protocol
um uh with the UK government
um you know everybody believed that this
would this would work already Minister
how can you not how can Northern Ireland
be completely rudderless um but it's
Northern Ireland's not rudderless in
fact that's that's really quite untrue
what Northern Ireland is is local
devolved government to work which is set
up 25 years ago 25 years ago by the
Belfast Good Friday agreement the
institutions do need to work and when
they are working they really do help
with peace and prosperity
um across Northern Ireland my job is to
try and get them back to work the big
office article is the Northern Ireland
protocol everybody the European
commission the UK government Irish
government people in Northern Ireland
everybody realizes it's a problem that
needs to be solved it needs to be solved
by an honest understanding and respect
and Trust on both sides we have that and
now not having the elections this in
this calendar year has cleared some
space for the elections be
um so I haven't moved them that far into
the future
um I've given myself two periods of six
weeks
um so three months uh yeah and so uh
look
that essentially means the first three
months of next year so there will be an
election there will be an election in
the first three months of next year
you sure yeah positive yeah okay
um talk to me um about
Gavin Williamson
um Gavin Williamson's resigned I know he
has what did you think about what he had
to say
um well he did something he allegedly
did something that is very which is a
very serious allegation um a very very
serious allegations
um against him so he was right to resign
was he should he have been given a job
in the first place I mean I was looking
at some reports overnight suggesting
that the Prime Minister knew about these
allegations and still gave him a job
yeah well I'm I haven't heard or seen
any evidence of that and what if it's
true as you will recall I was the
government Chief whip for I know uh for
six months that language
um I I would never have used language
like that um that's not my style but
maybe that's why I'm not Chief whip
anymore because does the chief whip need
to use that sort of no I think the chief
what but Chief whip does need to be um
be firm and
um but you know Gavin Williams the
allegations against him are very serious
and he's resigned and that was the right
thing to do yeah but should he have been
given the job in the first place
um uh he was given a job I don't know
what the what people knew at what times
and um so I'm not going to comment on
speculation like that but what if the
Prime Minister did know was it it's a
lot of what is isn't it no not really
yeah because the suggestion is that he
did know yeah
sort of on the premise is almost tinted
at the fact that he knew something was
going on right but he needed his support
I think that's all speculation and and
the wonderful thing about
um the United Kingdom is that you are
innocent until you're proven guilty he's
resigned from his post
um there's investigations going on and
that's the right and proper thing to
happen what do you think of him as a man
you obviously know him um I actually
don't know him quite well although he
did give me my first
um job he was Chief Whip and I was a
whip a very Junior whip in in his office
um and uh you know he he was he was a
half decent boss
even though he allegedly tells people to
Slit their throats and jump out of women
I've never seen that behavior in him
which is why I say you're innocent until
you're proven guilty and let the
investigation take its take its place
okay and as far as Matt Hancock is
concerned yeah well he should be here
with us
um voting and and debating in Parliament
did you watch him on the Telly no I'm
afraid I don't watch it don't tell
anybody do you not watch it well it's
very good actually yeah it is but um he
he did look at a bit of a book yesterday
it has to be said it does look as though
he's gonna going to get a very hard time
I so I know the format of the show and
um I I do believe there's quite a lot of
people in a building not too far away
from here the House of Commons and the
House of Lords who've downloaded a
certain app so they can vote I'm not
sure if that's a good thing is that
right yeah yeah that's a great story is
that true yeah of course it is wow
that's amazing um so you think that he
should be here you think it's totally
inappropriate that an MP should be the
other side of the world I mean I I've
read this morning what he said about why
Harry wants to prove that all you know
all in MP's a human and that's actually
you know that is true all MPS are human
but
um I think we do that every day in our
constituencies and and what we do in
Parliament okay you've got a girl like
me haven't you I wish you better thank
you thanks very much for joining us much
appreciated thank you uh it's great to
see you
um looking at the papers for you this
morning and several of them including
the Telegraph lead with the nurses
strike which will be the first national
walkout away from that the Metro focuses
on food banks and the report that warns
their at a Breaking Point this morning
Democrats avoid crushing defeats as the
Ft but points are still at risk of
losing control of Congress the express
reports on the Home Secretary swella
bravaman pushing police to take a firmer
approach to deal with Eco protesters and
the Seven goes with Jennifer Aniston
talking about her painful efforts years
ago as to become a mum which failed
no food banks say excuse me they are
dealing with a tsunami of need that has
put them at Breaking Point they've given
out 1.3 million emergency Parcels in the
last six months alone Aisha is standing
by for us this morning hi Asia it's good
to see you thanks for joining us they're
really Under Pressure aren't they
yeah that's right the trust all trust
has said that food banks are at breaking
point because of the tsunami of need
there's a record number of people
needing food banks at the moment in that
six months period six month period like
you said uh 1.3 million emergency
Parcels were delivered to people that
was around 320 000 people that they were
helping and of those 1.3 million meals
around half of those half a million went
to Children it means that the strain is
really being felt at places like here
City Harvest our food distribution
charity they help provide around 1.1
emergency meals to around 350
organizations and food banks supporting
people who require the help and they say
they're feeling the strain they first
started feeling pressure when the
pandemic began after that it did settle
it plateaued but now they say that
demand has skyrocketed and given the
current economic crisis as well they say
that it's becoming increasingly
difficult to get the donations in from
retailers because of the economic
situation and that's something that the
Trussell trust also highlighted they
said that at the moment needs are
exceeding donations so they've called on
the government to provide adequate
support in their upcoming budget
lovely thank you for now thanks
Joe Biden said last night that Americans
had sent a clear and unmistakable
message that they wanted to preserve
democracy as Democrats didn't win but it
is becoming clear that Donald Trump lost
the former president had been hoping for
a red wave that would give him the
momentum to launch a new bid for the
white house instead the tide went out on
the candidates he supported Joe standing
by in Phoenix again for us this morning
hi Joe
um you were reflecting on what might be
now that the results are in proper what
can you tell us
well I think it's becoming slightly more
clear what could happen in the next
couple of years okay clearly it's very
important who is up and who is down in
the midterms who is in and out of the
house representatives and of the Senate
but the the bigger International
significance is how all of this affects
the next race for the White House in
2024 and indeed if the two big beasts
who fought the last contest fight the
next one
he is the most unpopular US president of
modern times but Joe Biden's Democrats
have achieved a historically good set of
results it was a good day I think for
democracy
and I think it was a good day for
America he lost fewer seats in the House
of Representatives than any Democratic
President's first midterm election in
the last 40 years
and we had the best midterm for
Governors since 1986. he is savoring
some rag good news hey Buddy Joe Biden
congratulations man congratulations
especially with doubts over whether a
man who turns 80 in 10 days time will
run for re-election
congratulations my intention is that I
run again but I'm a great respecter of
fate and this is ultimately a family
decision my guess is to be early next
year we make that judgment another
possible candidate for the 2024 race is
holed up at his Mar-A-Lago Resort after
many of Donald Trump's candidates failed
to make waves there are reports he is
angry and wounded especially after the
success of his Republican rival Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis
counting continues in Nevada and Arizona
for two Senate seats which could decide
who has control of the Upper House in
Phoenix Arizona far from Washington
views on the next occupant of the White
House are mixed
I don't know
I really hope Trump doesn't run I'd like
to see him get indicted but
as for Biden I don't know kind of
indecisive I'm not saying I'm a trump
supporter
like you're not going to see me with a
mega hat on
but I think he's better than Joe Biden
Joe Biden is much older who should we be
watching I do ride to shannonis without
a doubt right to Santa's set himself up
last night whilst it could be a few more
days before we have the final results
here Nationwide there are clear and
consequential Trends and the balance of
power particularly in the Republican
Party seems to be shifting
as the electability of one Contender and
the candidacy of another are being
questioned it is very possible the Old
Guard will soon be replaced with new
faces
and in recent hours evidence that key
parts of the Republican establishment
may be turning against Donald Trump just
look at this front page of Rupert
Murdoch's New York Post the headline
trumpety Dumpty Don who couldn't build a
wall had a great fall can all the gop's
men put the party back together again
the paper saying that Donald Trump
sabotaged Republicans in the midterms
meanwhile there are widespread reports
okay that some of Donald Trump's
advisors are encouraging him to delay
the announcement expected next Tuesday
that he will launch a campaign for the
White House again he has commented on
this saying we had tremendous success at
the midterms I think he meant why would
anything change but it's certainly
possible in the coming hours and coming
days he does change
okay for now thanks very much indeed
thanks a lot
uh coming up on the program we'll ask
NHS providers about how safety and Care
can be provided during the nurses strike
the former England goalkeeper Arsenal
goalkeeper as well David Seaman on the
Three Lions World Cup chances as we wait
to hear who's in the 26 month Squad
they'll be heading to Casa
but before all of that some of today's
other headlines and the ministry of
Defense says it will shortly complete
the delivery of a further thousand
surface-to-air missiles to Ukraine the
defense secretary Ben Wallace said it
followed a request for more air defenses
to protect the country's critical
infrastructure from Russian drones
a man accused of attacking the husband
of the U.S House speaker Nancy Pelosi
has been charged with assault and
attempted kidnapping by a grand jury in
San Francisco Paul Pelosi was attacked
with a hammer during a break-in at the
couple's home last week
the second and Final Phase of the
grenful public inquiry ends today it was
set up to look into what happened at
Grenville Tower and the fire in which 72
people died the council that owned the
24-story building has apologized
unreservedly for the way it failed its
residents
Russia says it's withdrawing troops from
Kirsten in the south of Ukraine to
protect the life and health of its
service Personnel they had occupied the
city since March declaring it forever
Russia Curson lies on the river to nepro
it's a significant Target in its own
right and a gateway to Crimea Ukrainian
soldiers in the region are engaged in
hard fighting uh correspondent Alex
Rossi has been with an artillery team
near the village of David Bridge
they need to work quickly
their position just a few kilometers
from Enemy Lines is exposed and in the
line of fire the Drone pilot who's known
by his call sign Playboy is scouting out
where best to attack uh here is the
Russians
here is he going to the trench you see
yep
yeah yeah
you can see the Russians over here
that's incoming but they are taking huge
risks whilst they can see the enemy the
Russians also have drones
and they can be easily spotted
this is dangerous work but without this
eye in the sky Ukraine's artillery Crews
would be firing blind
further back from the front line troops
from the unit a volunteer platoon called
Carlson which includes foreign soldiers
load up with ammunition
huh
it's going good
um we're pushing them back and they're
falling back and unfortunately they're
destroying everything as they go
with winter on its way the fight for
kerson has become more desperate Ukraine
eager to take advantage of its momentum
and Russia's retreats
it's an artillery battle and it is
absolutely deadly now this team has just
been given the coordinates by the Drone
reconnaissance unit and they're heading
now to fire rockets at Russian positions
done
the launch position has been primed and
it doesn't take long to line up the
targets
there is no time to hang around the
firing needs to be done at speed
[Music]
images captured by drones show the
impact it's these kind of barrages that
are forcing the Russians to withdraw
but even before the Smoke Clears the
Ukrainian artillery team are making
their escape they're vulnerable now to a
rapid Counter-Strike
this fight is a clash of nerve and
Firepower and for the moments on this
perilous Frontier Ukraine is winning
Alex Rossi Sky News in curtain region
talking about uh more about that in just
a few moments um and also speaking to an
MP from Ukraine that to come refines on
the show as well what's the weather
doing
anticipation is rising and so is the
atmosphere are you ready
the weapon sponsored by Qatar Airways
turning milder by Friday Wind and Rain
largely confined to the North and the
West before then there'll be a many dry
start today but it'll be cloudy and
windy with Gales in the northwest
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
no it's not every day that you receive a
gift from a princess but at three years
old I came from North London has managed
to do just that chatting with the
Princess of Wales younger Kim managed to
eye up her royal British Legion Poppy
and Kate was happy to oblige
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
do you know what this is cool
it's remembering all the soldiers
oh there you go that's for you
look after it yeah maybe
lovely time now for a look at some of
the other photos that are caught our eye
today the York guard welcomed the
arrival of King Charles and the queen
consort at micklegate bar in York in a
traditional ceremony the bells of York
Minster rung out for the royal visit
uh there you go you got extra nothing
didn't he yesterday but managed to dodge
them quite niftily uh Christmas coming
and the small village of ardingly in
Sussex definitely can't escape it
they're home to the UK's tallest living
Christmas tree which can be seen at
wakehurst Gardens this year has been
decorated with 1800 energy saving
bulbs we got those pictures
there it is
um and worth remembering that there's a
place actually I think in Berkshire
called Christmas uh meantime it was the
job of this man Russell Croft to make
all the final checks on the 37 meter
giant Redwood and of course we had to
throw in some cute animal picks for you
these the First new seal pops of the
season to be born on the farn islands
off the coast of Northumberland even
waving at us good morning good morning
uh more on the nursery strike coming up
we'll speak to the organization that
represents NHS trusts and we'll also
hear from the Royal College of
anesthetists all of that to come in just
a few moments time to stitch it
everybody very good morning to you
watching the breakfast show here on Sky
News Thursday morning cabinet minister
uh Chris Heaton Harris has told me he's
very sad to see reports of nurses
resorting to eating patients leftovers
and using food banks as they prepare to
take unprecedented strike action
an advisement hinted at running for a
second White House term after
Republicans failed to make predicted
gains in the midterms
and family and friends have held a
service for a British man who has been
killed fighting alongside Ukrainian
forces against Russia
[Music]
foreign
in the last half an hour I've been
speaking to the Northern Ireland
secretary Chris Heaton Harris we began
with the nurses strike he disagreed with
the cabinet colleague who told me
yesterday that the industrial action is
pointless but he did say it will cause
significant disruption and Mr Heaton
Harris conceded that reports of nurses
having to eat patients leftovers are
upsetting
I've heard those stories too and they've
been and they're troubling and actually
very very sad but everything the
government is doing across the whole of
of public sector pay which is the only
pay sector that we can influence is is
aiming at the the lower paid and the
more more vulnerable in society as well
when we offer more packages of support
um so we understand that we need to help
people a bit more
um Minister the education secretary was
on yesterday said there's no point in
nurses going on strike because there's
no more money
um do you agree with that
I'd never say strike is pointless but
this completely disrupts a huge host of
Public Services
that are very very important to the
whole nation and dialogue is always the
best way
Tamara is uh here with us and tomorrow
what are you making what do you have to
say this morning morning well morning
how are ministers going to resolve the
first ever nurses strike which is going
to have huge implications for patients
although people will still be able to
get emergency care they are Keen to
stress of course to have what's
essentially a bank holiday service over
the very stretched winter period
especially with people already waiting a
long time for cancer treatment is going
to be devastating for a lot of patients
but nurses say they do they're doing
this for patients because the profession
has been has seen people leave in droves
there are lots of unfilled posts tens of
thousands of unfilled nursing posts
because people can't live on the wages
they say that they are getting which is
why they are pushing for an inflation
plus five point rise so a 17 rise given
inflations where it is at the moment
Steve Barkley the new health secretary
says that's too high and that's going to
cost nine billion pounds which is six
percent of the whole NHS budget is there
a um is there a compromise that they can
make well of course it involves getting
around the table and ministers wanting
to make a compromise and what will be in
the back of their minds is if you offer
nurses more than they've already been
given this year then of course strike
ballots coming from potentially Junior
doctors ambulance workers in England and
Scotland Hospital cleaners and other NHS
staff where does that leave those
negotiations yeah interesting um about
Matt Hancock as well so he should be
here with us yes that's it seems to be
the line from ministers
um they're often asked why Boris Johnson
was able to go to the Caribbean or Liz
trust able to go to on a sort of post
Prime ministerial holiday and not
represent their constituents but he says
they that Matt Hancock should be here
with his constituents he was tackled
about that on the show last night
actually but he says that he is being
with the people and getting big
audiences for his Antics in the jungle
yeah certainly that and uh who's
actually voting for him to do all of
these tasks
I so I know the format of the show and
um I I do believe there's quite a lot of
people in a building not too far away
from here the House of Commons and the
House of Lords who've downloaded a
certain app so they can vote I'm not
sure if that's a good thing is that
right yeah yeah that's a great story is
that true yeah of course it is
oh I'm urgently investigating
[Laughter]
would you vote for him to do tasks I
don't think that would be uh ethical in
my job but I know quite a few uh people
in Parliament who say that they have
okay it's good to talk to you thanks a
lot we'll see you at the top of the hour
meantime let's take you uh to chat to
saffron cordray the interim chief
executive of NHS providers which
represent NHS services that treat
patients hi it's good to see you thanks
for joining us how concerned are you
about what's likely to happen
well obviously the fact that we are now
going to see industrial action by nurses
is is concerning but what we have to
remember is that trust leaders up and
down the country will be preparing for
this their key responsibility is to make
sure that
those who need emergency and
um life and treatment for
life-threatening conditions will
continue to receive that and indeed next
week there is um an exercise being
undertaken across the NHS in England to
make sure that services will be in place
particularly given that this industrial
action is likely to take place over the
winter period but preparations are being
made
are you in support of nurses action
I think what we have to remember is that
the conditions that have led nurses to
this action we we completely understand
how strongly they feel below inflation
pay Awards rising cost of living we
heard that earlier in your piece we've
we've heard these Tales of of nurses
resorting to food banks many trusts are
setting up school uniform banks for
example to support nurses and others in
in you know the the basic costs of
living and also we have to remember that
that the NHS has been struggling for a
long time in terms of
um staff shortages and workloads that
have really been rocketing so we
understand the circumstances I think
what we want to see is the government to
come round the table with the unions to
actually reach a resolution on this
dispute because that's the most
important element of this we we
understand the conditions that have led
nurses to strike but what we have to see
now is the government come around the
table
so does that mean that you are
supporting them
I think what I'm talking about is it's
not my role to say whether I do or don't
support nurses I'm here representing
trust leaders whose job it is to
actually
make sure that we have safe services and
emergency services in place
um every nurse has the right to withdraw
labor as every individual does in this
country if if they have voted to do that
and if the you know if the law says that
they can then they can but what I'm here
to do is to talk about how trust leaders
up and down the country will actually
focus on making sure that there are
Services there for patients and their
carers to use how appalled are you to
hear that nurses are using food banks
and eating food left over from patients
oh deeply and I'm really concerned about
this and we did a survey NHS providers
did a survey earlier this year that
looked at the impact of the rising cost
of living on the NHS both in terms of
what it does to NHS budgets in terms of
inflation but also what it means for
staff and we know that those
particularly on on Lower pay grades are
really struggling one of the things
we're particularly concerned about is
actually retaining staff in the NHS
experienced staff and and making sure
that they don't leave NHS positions to
go and work in for example retail or
Hospitality which in the in the run-up
to Christmas is a possibility for many
of those more Junior stuff we don't want
to see that happen we know that the NHS
staff are incredibly well trained and
committed and we want to see them
staying in their role the NHS needs them
and patients need them
um and what are we saying to concern
patients who you know there's already
seven million people that are waiting
for a procedure on the NHS that's just
going to get worse isn't it
well obviously no one wants to see this
disruption um because the NHS has been
working incredibly hard to clear that
backlog I think what patients need to
know is that the NHS is undergoing this
exercise next week to make sure that
that that safety will be preserved and
it may mean that some procedures are
delayed or or moved to another day and
we we know that that is deeply upsetting
for people who have planned for a
procedure and we know that people have
been waiting longer than they should I
think what we have to remember is that
that the NHS and and trusts up and down
the country have been doing what they
can to get activity levels up to make
sure that they get through as many of
those operations as possible so yes no
one wants to see potential delays to
that but we may well see them but I
think what everyone knows and doesn't
underestimate is the the potential
distress and disruption that that will
cause individuals absolutely good to
talk to you thank you
thank you that's also bringing the vice
president of the Royal College of
anesthetist that's Helga Johansson um
hello two thank you for joining us
um one of my current challenges that uh
you and your members are facing every
day
absolutely I think listening to what
saffron said um about staff shortages we
definitely see that day to day
um we've identified for anesthesis uh 10
recruitment Gap we have a 10 vacancy
um but this this goes throughout the NHS
and um I suspect figures later on this
morning will show an increase in in
waiting times as well for our patients
which absolutely breaks our heart I
think it's really important that we
don't just think about
um uh retention as saffron said but we
also think about uh Recruitment and
training
um and we haven't seen the the
recruitment increase and the training
increase that we need we need to
increase our training capacity to allow
us to cope with the with the increased
um increased demand that there are on
our services at the moment okay
um what what's the situation though when
it comes to nurses and Denise is working
with nurses and your concerns about the
fact that they're having to use food
banks in order to survive according to
reports
so we work in a team
um some of my close friends are nurses
and um and I know that that what what
they've been going through in the last
few years has been pretty bad
um I know that they will not have taken
the decision to strike lightly
um and I know that it will absolutely
have wrecked that they will have racked
their brains before they voted yes
um what options are open to anesthetist
to try to improve their conditions
um
it's called say really the
um in an operating theater is very much
a team game and you need all the cogs in
the um in the in the machine to work
very well
um we are one part of that Cog um we
need to increase the be able to increase
our training and our recruitment to
close those gaps to allow our patients
to get the operations that they need in
the meanwhile the patient surgical
condition is getting worse the longer
they wait these conditions don't get
better and so the operations become more
difficult so it's absolutely imperative
that we as an NHS and and as a team in
total do our best to try and get those
patients through
put strike action is not something that
your colleagues would consider is it
appropriate that nurses are going on
strike
it's not my
um it
it's not my role to comment on on the
strike per se but as I said earlier I
know that they will not have taken this
decision lightly it's important to
remember that in order to retain staff
you need to treat them well and you need
to pay them well and that in the last 10
years Healthcare staff have taken the
brunt of the uh of the austerity
austerity measures and we've seen a pay
freeze probably for about 10 years now
you can do that for only so long and
then you need to do something about it
how do you feel about former Health
secretary getting paid 400 000 pounds to
go into the jungle
um I have to say I wouldn't go to the
Jungle myself for 400 000 pounds
um and um I I'd much rather do the job
that I'm doing here um I'll be doing my
job this morning
um in the in the NHS and I'm looking
forward to
um getting there later on this morning
does it irritate you that he's there
does it irritate me that he's there
um yes to be honest this is me speaking
as a person
um he has a job to do and um and uh I
can't go to the Jungle because
um I wouldn't be doing the job that I'm
contracted to do
um so from that point of view yes okay
thanks for joining us much appreciated
thank you
official figures analyzed by Sky News
show that Britain is in the grip of a
mental health crisis that's fueling
labor shortages more than 450 000 people
have stopped working in the past three
years due to conditions such as anxiety
and depression guppert Darwin have more
for us
workers battling the elements on their
way to the office it's almost as if the
pandemic never happened
but the lockdowns have left some scars I
was struggling at work I felt depressed
I felt alone
James suffered a mental health crisis in
early 2020. his employer paid for some
counseling but it was not enough
they came back to me to say it's you've
spent your budget and we can't
support you any longer in terms of
giving you mental health support
so
that was probably my lowest point he's
not alone
people have been leaving the world of
work in record numbers mainly because of
long-term sickness
levels of economic inactivity among the
long-term SEC have risen by more than
half a million since the pandemic
the majority of this increase is related
to mental health problems
and a growing number of people in work
are also reporting long-term health
problems
the key driver mental health conditions
after hitting rock bottom James received
help from a specialist company one of a
growing number that are trying to solve
this problem
this is a portal you don't have to go
through anyone in the company to access
it Joel's set up an online platform to
help employers offer more tailored
support to their workers
you've got lots of your Workforce Now
suffering depression suffering more
anxiety if you don't support your
Workforce you're going to have poor poor
employee outcomes which are going to
create poor business outcomes
an issue that affects everybody
businesses are struggling to recruit
they may be forced into paying higher
wages
good for some but a concern for the bank
of England which fears that it could
fuel price pressures at a time when
inflation is already running rampant
there's a recession on the horizon and a
cost of living crisis in full flow all
of this will take a toll on a country
already in the grip of a mental health
crisis
gurpreet nawan Sky News
and later this morning the latest NHS
performance figures will be released for
hospitals in England including waiting
times and canceled operations we'll have
live coverage here on Sky News from half
past nine
now here's a sign of the times Malta
attracting Visitors by telling them they
can spend weeks on the island and won't
have to heat their homes and that adds
to its claims to be one of the most
sustainable tourist destinations we were
talking about it actually with the CEO
of Thomas Cook earlier this week and he
said Malta is very very popular with
Brits so what we thought was we'd get
the Maltese tourism minister in and here
he is Clayton Bartolo hello to you thank
you good morning joining us why do Brits
go to Malta there are a number of
reasons why Bruce should come to Malta
it's an all-around destination at least
obviously at the moment the winter sun
which is coming and this morning in fact
it's a perfect day and moved once again
so all that together with all that is to
do there is a perfect package
destination for everybody to visit and a
lot of people from Britain do come not
least because it's cheaper to go to
Malta than it is to heat your home yes
it is and when one is there then he can
have an affordable holiday together with
his family something which I believe
everybody should be looking for now in
these times you spend some some quality
time with with your friends as well and
there's so much to do whether it is
sampling some of our local Cuisine there
are at least 30 restaurants which are
now listed in the Michelin guide and a
lot of other traditional restaurants
which can offer you traditional cuisine
which is obviously very well known for
in the Mediterranean a number of events
as well which will be taken up in the
coming weeks and months we have for
example Cirque du Soleil which will be
running live a special show made
especially for Malta nice we will have a
lot of Christmas events going on and
apart from that there's very good
connectivity between Malta and the UK
something which we have been working on
over the past few weeks as well to
ensure that next year's connectivity is
even better than this year so people
come for longer than just a couple of
weeks excuse me I'll get some water from
Luke in a second
um and that is I'm guessing then they're
older are they yes in fact at the moment
we're also promoting long stays so
something which it is uh good for winter
as well in the winter months you
wouldn't have the same cold temperatures
which you get in Mainland Europe
something which is totally different
than other countries we are well
renowned for having well over 300 days
of sunshine and the one would also like
to visit for example to have 365
churches that's one church for every day
wow most of which have you seen all of
them no not yet actually that's a good
point what about sustainability yes on
that aspect then we are working very
hard as well with the accommodation
sector whether it is hotels or whether
it is private accommodation to ensure
that Energy Efficiency is at the top of
the agenda on that aspect the government
has also intervened in a positive manner
when the energy crisis hit to ensure
that the energy bullies do not increase
and that means that the rates remain
uncompetitive so that in itself is
already a measure of affordability
for everyone who wants to visit Malta at
the same time we're also protecting the
local families and the local businesses
to ensure that they are not hard hit do
you get the impression that tourists
particularly Brits who come to Malton
are more interested than they ever were
about sustainability yeah sustainability
shouldn't be just a buzzword in fact in
our tourism industry nowadays we are
talking more about responsible travel
and green travel and the fact that
everyone should in fact be responsible
for his own admissions even when
traveling so on the test pack the motor
tourism Authority will be launching a
project very soon to ensure that while
ensuring that everyone is made aware of
his responsibilities then we have to own
up for our responsibilities because at
the end of the day whether you're a
bridge coming to Malt or whether you're
a multi is coming to the UK everybody is
responsible yeah um cop 27 talking a lot
about sustainability and heating of the
planet what's malta's involvement been
with cop 27. our prime minister has been
a decoupled 27 and once again he
reassured that Malta even those modern
size will be be doing its part to ensure
that the sustainable guidelines are up
Captain Malta and we are also in line
with the unwto's Declarations
um are concerned if they want to stay
for longer that there are no problems
with that when it comes definitely not
Visa issues or anything like that
nothing like that in fact um the
relationship between more than the UK
has been a very good one for a very long
time English is in fact one of our
national languages so that means that
it's very convenient for Brits to come
and stay in Malta Malta is practically
very well connected not just with London
but with various airports around the UK
so that makes it very easy for everybody
who would like to spend some time in
Malta and Sunday Malta and to just get a
flight and hop over okay I mean I have
to say one of my guilty pleasures is um
below deck Med
um and that's based in Malta isn't it
did you know that yes it is beautiful
what was that what's that place called
where the where the dock is it's
beautiful they're on the Grand Harbor
okay that is that is the my opinion is
the nicest Harbor one can have and it's
a natural Harbor as well okay so we're
welcome there are thousands of passenger
cruise tourists every year and everybody
is simply astounded and an interesting
fact is the fact that when cruise ships
are docking in the ship's Captain he
tells everybody
well yes
and she tells everyone that it's worth
it to wake up even earlier to what
towards the ship dropping in okay so do
you watch below deck Med as well yes do
you Captain Sandy's yeah the boss isn't
it if you don't watch it at home you
really should it's great to talk to you
thank you so much for joining us really
appreciate it thank you our interview
came about uh because the chief exec as
I said of Thomas Cook was on the show
saying that a lot of Brits are going to
uh Malta over the next few months if
you've got a story that you'd like us to
cover then get in touch see what happens
quick look at the weather
anticipation is rising and so is the
atmosphere are you ready
the weapon sponsored by Qatar Airways
uh it might be beautiful in Malta it's
not bad here either apparently milder by
Friday Wind and Rain largely confined to
the North and the West mainly dry now
but quite cloudy and windy with Gales in
the Northwest rain for parts of Northern
Scotland and a little drizzle elsewhere
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways